now hold on don't talk about it I have a
revelation about George so last week we
were wrapping up the podcast and we were
talking about you know how we were
talking with Margaret about how who we
get mistaken for yeah and you were like
oh I get mistaken for just about every
Asian like steve aoki or whatever so
George and I were wrapping up here and
he goes he's like you're never gonna
believe this
but I was mistaken for Brad Pitt and
they actually asked me that okay never
tell this story cuz nobody believes me
no no no his defense the person was
blind nobody that what you just said
there nobody believes you right you
should be the thing that you put your
anchor in okay but also babe he signed
an autograph
he said you signed it was an Argentine
people they're white in Argentina weird
brown messy tell us a story George okay
I'd gone down there for a girl then like
we broke it up it was like my couple
weeks before like leaving home uh-huh I
was walking through it like a a big old
mall and by scientist just I went late
finish I just need I need a second
I might burst into laughter I might just
die right now so I just need a break I
need a second just to catch my breath
okay
this is so crazy okay slow it down
before I die I don't want a guy right I
don't want to die okay I had a I had a
hat on so like there wasn't much face go
off and I was just walking this mall I
see some teeny boppers over there the
girls we're gonna look mushrooms and at
the same time they were looking at me
I'd like but did my circle in the mall I
came back and then one of them really
timidly comes out she's like I like all
of her friends were over there like
looking yeah yeah yeah and I was started
to sign my name and there was like who
am i it's just like you're
but I write and I was like no yeah and
it's a goddamn true story you might have
had an extra chromosome but no problem
and you call them dinners welcome Tina
reality is this so reality is this he
was at a bar listen this is the real
story oh yeah George is a bar no one
wanted to hang out with him our
entertainment so he's by himself
yeah okay god I want to get some [ __ ]
or whatever but no one's looking at me
right and some guy comes up to goes
anybody drink this right he drinks it
and it's full of like hallucinogenics
and drunk right he blacks out right yeah
but in this blackout right he makes it
to his hotel room
right so now envision this a naked
George in his bathroom on his patch on
that where he takes a [ __ ] yeah and he's
going through the scene in his head yeah
yeah this is a hallucinogenic you know
mean dream that he made up and either
living out a fantasy in his mind yes
it's a fantasy that embarrasses me every
time people don't believe this guy
it only comes out every so often when I
think I have trust I think they're with
you who was there with you I need
[ __ ] yeah it was only me we cannot it
cannot accept your story and Angelina
and the kids yeah yeah you don't look
anything like them
who's the what celebrity right now you
don't have to lie
[Music]